david vous êtes au palais-bourbon débat
consacré aujourd'hui au suivi de la
crise sanitaire qui intervient donc
après un conseil de défense
essentiellement axé sur la vaccination
effectivement un conseil de défense ans
et elisabeth board qui sort tout juste
de l'hôpital ensuite à son infection aux
copies des 19 laissant roselyne bachelot
la ministre de la culture qui fait le
chemin inverse également atteinte du
coït 19
alors suite aux déclarations d' emmanuel
macron hier tout le débat porte
maintenant sur la vaccination elle de
masse la pénurie de doses et les retards
de livraison viennent contrarier le
planning de vaccination est de
l'exécutif
un seul un responsable elle pourra
gabriela talent astrazeneca lé porte
parole du gouvernement accuse le
laboratoire britannique aux suédois de
ne pas tenir ses engagements avec
l'union européenne l'union européenne
qui est justement toute la source du
problème pour nicolas dupont aignan
écoutez moi ce que je demande c'est
qu'on reprenne notre liberté vis-à-vis
de l'union européenne et que la france
mène sa politique comme israël comme
l'angleterre comme les états unis libre
on peut acheter des vaccins en russie on
peut avec ses acheter des vaccins
chinois ont on peut aussi comparer les
vaccins pourquoi être prisonnier
d'accord qui de toute façon ne sont
respectées par personne on ne connaît
même pas les clauses de commandes
l'union européenne refuse les publier on
ne sait même pas quel est le prix
d'achat
donc il ya vraiment un problème de
fonctionnement c'est l'union européenne
qui décide des bureaucrates non élus
soumis à des influences de laboratoire
pharmaceutique quand même en général et
donc voilà faut pas s'étonner si on
confine au affaire à des gens
incompétents
bien que les résultats soient
catastrophiques donc moi j'aimerais
qu'on reprenne notre liberté qu'on
puisse commander les vaccins qu'on veut
qu'on puisse avoir des études plus
approfondies
car je vous rappelle que le vaccin
astrazeneca est toujours interdit en
norvège qui n'est pas autorisé aux états
unis et qui a peut-être d'autres vaccins
une séance très peu suivie et cet après
midi à l'assemblée nationale les débats
ne sont ne se sont pas portés uniquement
sur la vaccination mais également sur
l'espoir de retrouver un semblant de
liberté pour l état français est les
restrictions qui s'accumulent sont
synonymes d'atteintes aux libertés
fondamentales pour l'opposition qui a
pointe a également l le fossé abyssal
des inégalités sociales provoquées par
la crise sanitaire l'occasion aussi de
faire un bilan un an après la guerre
contre le virus est toujours d'actualité
elle s'est même renforcée au vu des
derniers chiffres plus qu'alarmant la
pression italien a presque atteint son
point de rupture notamment en ile de
france d'où la possibilité pour
l'exécutif de prendre de nouvelles
mesures encore plus drastiques dans les
régions concernées merci david khalifa
pour toutes ces précisions direct donc
de l'assemblée nationale